okay
meeting is now live chair
welcome councillors to this meeting
this is a public meeting being streamed
live to you
youtube and via the council's website
the meeting has also been recorded for
purposes
of the minutes i have been advised that
the live stream is now up and running
if any if for any reason the public can
no longer hear
or see the meeting over the live stream
we will adjourn
until the connection has been
reestablished
can i ask the governance manager to
explain the procedure for the meeting
and to confirm the members and officers
present
thank you chair um as advised to members
before the meeting we're asking for
members to keep their
microphones muted during the duration of
the meeting apart from the point in
which they would like to speak
um members are also asked to keep their
cameras off unless they wish to indicate
they want to speak in which case
they will show up on your screens in the
chamber chair
for voting if members would kindly turn
on your camera when you're asked to
commence the vote
the monitoring officer will ask you
whether you're voting for against or
abstain she'll ask
those members who are voting for to turn
their cameras on
first and then in turn voting will be by
a simple show of hands
and if members could clearly raise their
hands close to their face like this then
we will be able to see you
from the screens we are going to test
out
a poll vote for the minutes and we've
just had a trial run before the meeting
um and we will see whether we can do
this in future but all of the votes
will be done by a show of hands
thank you chair um in the meeting room
today are all the members of council
apart from those members who have
offered their apologies for the meeting
and they are councillors dayton
elliot holmes hunt
rouse and stone thank you chair
thank you
declarations of interest members of
interest should have declared them to
the governance manager in advance of the
meeting
however i will ask again can members
turn their cameras
on if they have any interest to declare
no members are indicating they have
interests sure
minutes of the last meeting can we
approve the minutes of the last meeting
as a true and accurate record
may i have a second
that's casa joe burke indicating he'd
like to second chair
no no no no sorry
hello councillor drew burke can wish us
to speak chair
thank you
thank you chair i just need to point out
that my attendance at those
in the minutes of the class two meetings
have been missed out and i was there on
the 18th of may but it's not in the
present list that's uh in the minutes
thank you please
subject to that amendment then check can
i propose them as a true and accurate
record
i'm happy to second jeff
thank you okay i've issued the poll to
all members for voting
i'll share the results with you in a
moment thank you
with 42 votes for that's carried chair
thank you sure
can i respectfully request that people
get closer to the microphones i'm having
a real difficulty in hearing some people
uh and it's exacerbated
as well as because there's a delay in
the video
so try to read the lips at the same time
there is
practically an impossible task so maybe
can we just ask
members to get closer to the microphone
please
thank you
can i go to chairs announcements
uh thank you colleagues given the
circumstances there is not much for me
to report
but i would like to inform you that the
new dean of derby the very reverend dr
peter robinson
took up his new role at the beginning of
july
the service of collection and
installation of the new dean will be
live streamed from the cathedral
on sunday the 19th of july i'm sure
i'm sure we can all wish him well
item five vote of thanks for the
outgoing leader of the council
and i'd like to say something on that
i would like it to be noted for the
record my sincere appreciation of the
dedication
commitment and service martin has given
over the years
he has been a beacon of the council
demonstrating strong leadership skills
and a future focused strategy
for me personally and i know for many
others too
in his role as leader he has been a
guiding light and has always been there
to offer support guidance
and friendly and friendly air he'll be
hard actor follow and i certainly wish
him every success in any projects he
undertakes in the future
thank you
good could i indicate my
my wish to speak yeah and mine please
after after alex thanks
thank you
counselor dale thank you check can i
start by um associating myself with with
the words you just
you just gave then um one of the first
occasions i met martin was actually in
an interview room
i was a budding young activist hoping to
be the conservative candidate for coal
aston ward in the 2015 election
and martin was at the other other side
of the table on the interview panel
despite quite a few tough questions
delivered in
in true head teacher style i'm pleased
to say i not only made it out alive but
was also
as a successful candidate and in spite
of this slightly nerve-wracking first
encounter
martin and i quickly became close
colleagues and good friends
and i feel extremely privileged to have
worked alongside him
as deputy group leader since 2016.
i know that martin's been a member of
the conservative party now for
37 years witnessing firsthand the
resounding victories
crushing defeats and everything else in
between along the way
his long and distinguished career in
local politics started in chesterfield
where he served as a borough councillor
from 1991 to 95
and during which time he rose to the
rank of group leader
but it was over the border in northeast
derbyshire that martin's political
career
really reached new heights in 2017 he
was elected to represent
sorry 2007 he was elected to represent
brampton walton ward
and i understand from martin that when
he first joined the conservative group
it met only very infrequently during his
first term
and was there there was rarely ever a
whip in place for any voting at full
council
but all of that came to an abrupt end in
2011
when martin was elected group leader he
implemented regular group meetings
a shadow cabinet system and the whip and
over the course of the next eight years
martin led an effective opposition
always jumping at the opportunity
to scrutinize the labour administration
and hold it to account
and as the group got better and better
so too did its fortunes
last may martin led us to victory to
become
uh the first conservative administration
ever to run north east derbyshire
district council
what makes the result so much more
impressive is actually when it's viewed
within the national context of some
pretty dire polling for the
conservatives
on the same day that martin became
leader of the council
the conservatives lost 44 other councils
in the country
and 1330 councillors
over the past year martin's led an
ambitious programme reform
with an administration that's got
straight to work in delivering on its
manifesto commitments
freezing council tax reducing the
leisure subsidy
structuring restructuring the senior
management team hosting jobs fairs
promoting neighborhood planning and
fighting fracking just to name a few
but arguably martin's finest
achievements have come
during the kobit 19 pandemic true to
form as the country fell into lockdown
martin's public service instincts ramped
up
and he helped to transform the function
of the council almost overnight
so that it could play a key role in
supporting our residents and communities
through the worst of it
during the pandemic the council has
telephoned over 7 000 people to offer
assistance
delivered over 4 000 medical supplies
delivered food
and new local newspapers and magazines
to hundreds of residents who are most
isolated
contacted over 1800 businesses to help
them access financial support
provided over 1500 grants to businesses
totaling almost 18 million pounds
awarded 350 businesses with a hundred
percent
uh business rates relief and received
over 20 000 calls and emails from
residents and businesses requesting
support and advice
and absolutely none of this would have
been possible without the leadership
that martin has
shown so on behalf of the council and in
particular the the conservative group
i want to thank martin for everything he
has done
both as group leader for the past nine
years and as leader of the council since
last may
with experience comes wisdom and on a
personal note i want to thank martin
for all of the advice and guidance he's
given me over the years on all matters
relating to politics and local
government
and it's been a great pleasure to have
served as martin's deputy
for the past four years i really have
learnt a heck of a lot from him
and i wish him very well in his future
endeavors i know he'll continue to have
a distinguished career
in public service and i'm very pleased
he'll still be able to continue as a
councillor
and play an active role in supporting
this administration
and the council as a whole thank you
chair
thank you councillor barker
well thank you chair can you all hear me
yes
i just like made the point that that i
don't think this it's not a reality and
it's not a political speech this
it's it's it is about martin i think uh
and to be honest i think it is a bit
surreal this
uh firstly about giving it to
councillor thakya martin as we call it
uh
you know that he's only been in this
role for only just over a year
and secondly to do it in this this
format where i can't see anybody apart
from somebody everybody's name
which is a bit a bit surreal to to try
and deal with that on a personal level
i can see you there martin in that
little box but you're still a long way
off
well having said all that i might be
more than happy to endorse a lot of
what's already been said
uh you know but while we're
we are in different political parties
obviously
i can still respect uh what martin's
done as a person and
and as a leader so i'd like to endorse
uh some of the comments in his last
briefing
and and the briefings have been
excellent martin and well received
to do them on a daily basis it must have
been a
a bit of a task but people have have
well received them
and i know that we have tried to work
together during the crisis
for the benefits for all the communities
in northeast derbyshire
uh and and i'd also like to put on
record
uh the labour groups thanks to all the
staff and the
the the leaders as you've done in your
briefing
i've also spoke to steve fritschler this
morning that you mentioned
and he's asked me to pass on his thanks
and best wishes
for the future uh and again i'd like to
finish it you know i want to wish you
well martin you're not
uh you're not dead you're not going
anywhere so wish you well in the future
uh and uh whatever your take on and i
just thought
that that the new leadership will carry
on
with the same philosophy inclusion and
partnership and
that you've shown and there you go
martin it's
i know you've waited a long while for
that chance and and obviously
things have taken a a different turn so
whatever you want to do in the future
best of luck mate
this meeting is being recorded
thank you chair um can i first of all
thank you for your very kind words
and the words of councillor dale and
councillor barker
i know i didn't quite make the 10 out of
10 nigel but uh that sounded as close as
i'll ever get
and i was reminded by some of my
colleagues that i have been involved in
politics
longer than they have been born
i started life in party politics in 1983
because i wanted to make a difference i
spent several years learning my trade
and developing a knowledge about
campaigning
i stood as a candidate for election for
the first time in 1989
and i was elected on my second attempt
in 1991.
i joined a council with many
long-serving councillors
some of them had been on the council
since the 1960s
and had much to offer i came to
appreciate that experience
in local government is a commodity to be
prized
i was first elected to north east
derbyshire district council in 2007
i had been approached by the then leader
of the conservative group
bill pickford who said my reputation as
a campaigner
meant something positive the deputy
leader at the time was the great
mike emmons both he and bill
understood that loyalty in politics is
to be valued
i hope my experience and positive
reputation
will be used as a force for good
in my new role it is with sadness that i
stepped down as leader of the council
however i have appreciated the support
of elected members from
across the chamber as well as that from
a number of dedicated staff
and to those people i extend a heartfelt
thanks i am proud to have been
responsible for a number of achievements
particularly the signing of the bsl
charter
campaigning for the rights of people who
are deaf has been the cause
closest to my heart for the majority of
my life
and will continue to be until the day i
draw my last breath
the council's response to covid19 has
been outstanding
while there has been personal cost to me
i take pride in all that has been
undertaken
to make a difference for residents in
this district
we truly have saved lives
during the pandemic i hope that
cross-party working has helped others
to have a better understanding of me
i have certainly gained a better
understanding of the leaders of the
other parties
and i am grateful for your assistance
and encouragement
this is not retirement
i will continue working hard for
residents in the ward i represent
with my friend and colleague peter
elliott i look forward to new roles
within council
and striving with all of you who
genuinely care
in making this district a great place to
be
thank you for the many messages of
kindness and congratulations
while i am eagerly anticipating new
challenges
i remain just as passionate about
politics
as i was in 1983 and
equally zealous about local government
as i was
when first elected in 1991.
thank you
thank you and council rebecca
going on then tonight item number six
the election of leadership
we have members indicating they'd like
to speak um
for your reference chair you have
councillor tracy reader council ross
shipman councillor barry lewis
oh sorry
can we have counselor reader
yes chad i'm really sorry i didn't mean
to come in before
martin began speaking but um again
martin just want to
echo um all the sentiments that you've
had
and and to say i wish you um lots and
lots of luck in your new role that
you're going to have
and also as you've said you're not going
to be going anywhere in the council so
i'm sure you will still be there to give
us hell on the other side of the chamber
um as you have done and but yes i just
wanted to say you know respect where i
respected you
with regards to the work that you've
been doing during the coronavirus
pandemic
and allowing us all and from different
parties to be involved in that process
and because it really has meant that
we've all had to pull together
um in this difficult time so thank you
for allowing that to
uh to happen and also i've known you
professionally martin so
um as well uh outside of this so
um thank you very much and and you will
be missed
counselor shipment
thank you chair um it'll come there's no
shock to anybody that counts lethal and
i have not always agreed on issues that
have come before council
but even though we've had robust debates
i know that he's always had the district
um first and foremost in front of his
mind when he's made the decisions that
he's made
you know he's always brought his humor
to um council which is always nice to
see because they can drag on a bit
sometimes
um and i would just like to echo
comments that during this screen of
virus crisis i would say that is
is an excellent job leading this
council's response
to that situation so if you know i'd
like to pass my thanks on again
for that um i'm stepping down we'll
leave some big boots to fill
um so um councillor dale will have um a
job on his hands to
match and do better than what um
councillor thakur has done
and i'd like to wish him well in his new
role and look forward to working with
him as a local councillor for the
in the interests of north east
derbyshire residents thank you
thank you council shipment is there
anyone else
can i say something please yes please do
i can't really use councillor john
fennell i can't really add to what's
already been
said regarding martin and i've endorsed
everything that's been spoken
what i would like to say is a big thank
you to martin for the last 12 months
because transition from one regime to
another then facing up for covid and all
the implications that goes with that
it took someone of some exceptional
capability and i think martin
in my book falls into that category so
i'd like to thank him for all the odd
work particularly over the last 12
months
thank you marty thank you
jack uh councillor charlotte cupid barry
lewis and david hancock
indicating they would like to speak
uh councillor cupert
thank you cher um again it's very
surreal to be doing it
by this way rather than us all being in
the chamber but we've moved to different
times at the moment
um so yeah it's hard to know where to
start in highlighting my thanks
and to council of so i'll just choose a
few examples which i think some people
have already echoed to illustrate what
i think my key appreciations and in the
knowledge that i could speak on
many more as i think has already been
highlighted by other speakers
as well as being a counselor councillor
backer takes the role of being a
councillor to its fullest extent
and works tirelessly to help wide
variety of residents charities and
communities across his ward
also across the district he's worked to
make sure this is at the heart of the
council's agenda
from the armed forces and veterans to
the local rspca
and there's a local school governor
chair of his parish council
many more um everyone i meet knows
council rebecca
i'm genuinely not sure how he finds the
time to be in so many places at once
and helped so many people i know he'll
always find time to talk to someone and
help him if he can
i know he'll continue to do that um i
think his has been echoed
i think this dedication has been
perfectly illustrated during kovid 19.
now so that has helped adapt and harness
the council to concentrate on helping
residents and businesses
with the specific challenges posed
probably at one of the most difficult
periods of our lifetimes
i've spoken to many residents just in my
ward who
have been helped by the council during
this time and are immensely grateful
and i know this is replicated across the
district
it's clear we've been a lot more
proactive than many other councils
so i pay thanks to officers and staff
also to councillor rebecca for leading
this and being there for so many
thousands of our residents when they
really needed us most
move on to a personal note i've been on
the council since 2015.
the council of waka's advice and
political wisdom have been invaluable to
me
in the steep learning curve i think we
all have for both how things work on a
practical level
but also how to make a real difference
for residents in our area
in the machinery of local government low
council attacker always maintains he's
only 27
so hopefully i won't betray that when i
say i know he's been on the council for
13 years
but his driving unrelenting work
projects help improve our area continues
undiminished
he's also led the incorporation and
focus our headline aim
of being a listening residence council
and being a listening council
and so i hope you never lose sight of
who we represent
and he's always happy to listen to
everyone this was the case throughout
our time in opposition but also over the
last 13 months
as leader it's been a real privilege and
honor to have served in his cabinet
um one for the final example um and i
hope will be united in the chamber in a
greens list
i'd like to note councillor backers
brilliant public speaking in the chamber
and at any event really
i'm always amazed how he always has the
speech ready and can adapt either to the
gravity
or the likeness of the situation public
speaking is tricky for many of us
and it's hard to sometimes know the
right thing to say the counselor that
could always have a bit of humor as we
mentioned
and you'll i always look to his example
in this where i can
and so on this note i hope and i know
i'll be able to continue to learn and
benefit from council attackers
experience
and tireless working local government
and making our area a bigger and a
stronger community
has been shown by code of 19. so i know
he'll continue to do all this but just
for today
um i want to also know my personal
thanks
thank you councillor lewis
uh thank you chairman and uh thank you
for the opportunity of speaking i'll
keep
i'll keep this brief but uh just uh just
to echo uh basically what everybody else
has said
um about councillor thakur um he's a
friend as well as a colleague i've known
uh council attacker now for a good
number of years we have
quite a shared history in many ways
particularly around family experiences
in terms of coming from
uh profoundly deaf family backgrounds we
also have shared histories in uh
in archaeology and uh and and and
history as well so as
shared interests really in those areas i
just wanted to say a couple of words
about
um uh council thakura and his uh his
outward-facing role as the
as a as the leader of northeast derby
district council
uh working in spheres like d2n2 and uh
in engagement with the
um derbyshire county council and many
other or external organizations
and i have to say that what uh
one thing that sort of sticks out really
about uh councillor thacker
he is an exemplary um advocate for
northeast derbyshire district council
and always shouted um his corner
for the district in every meeting that
uh that you will
you would ever like to see him on and i
just wanted to echo as well that uh what
other people have said he's always there
with a
with a ready story and a good um a good
narrative to uh to put to people
um superb public speaker and uh
and i'm pretty sure that uh um given all
the other roles that uh um the council
attacker has
he is uh going to be extremely busy uh
and will be busy well into the future
and and i just wanted to wish him um all
the best both as a
a colleague and a friend
thank you councillor hancock
thank you chair um i just wanted to add
add my
personal respect to martin we we don't
always see eye to eye we'll be allowed
to say we do but one thing which we do
share
and which hasn't really been touched on
very greatly is his huge passion
for the uh community that he serves and
martin has always gone into this
serving his community more than a
representative and
i think i'm glad he's staying on as a
counselor because he has so much
more to give he's given an awful lot
over the years he still does
and being the only lib dem that was here
pre-election and post-election
it has been and i don't really want to
make this political because ultimately i
think politics doesn't play a huge part
a local level
but um i think it has been nice to have
the inclusivity
and the fact that we have done this so a
personal mark of respect to martin on
that thank
thank you okay you have a number of
members still wishing to speak
those members with their camera on uh
councillor alan powell councillor
oscar gomez rooney councillor william
armitage
councillor philip wright and councillor
gerrymandering
uh councillor powell
as you know i'm a counselor a few words
so i'm going to say a few words
to describe martin
honorable decisive
fastidious knowledgeable
sagacious discerning
shrewd understanding
traditional prudent
dedicated and wise
thank you council attacker for all that
you've done and all that you are
still to do thank you
councillor oscarina
uh thank you chair i did just want to
say a personal
thank you to councillor so
when i first got elected last year i
definitely felt like i was the new kid
in school
the council was scary it was a big place
it felt really complicated and
mind-blowing
um but over the last 12 months
councillor thackeray has been a great
support for me
he's helped me settle into my new role
understand the workings of the council
and he has also placed great trust in me
so i do look forward to working further
with councillor thank you
sakasari and his continued work support
in our district
and i do also wish councillor thakur all
the best of luck
in his future endeavors
comes the mole
counselor morley
counselor philip wright
counselor armitage
hello can you hear me all right yes
counselor right
well it's a bit like doing a best man's
speech
so i won't tell them everything
all i would like to say is thank you uh
for your continued help and
advice divorce found it very sound uh
you're somewhat of a sage but
we don't always agree does you know uh
and i've probably uh
taught you a number of other words for
your vocabulary
uh which have been gained from being a
front row forward
but i'll just say this i'm sure you're
going to do
well from wherever you're going and
overall you're an all right guy
thank you again
thank you
councillor molly
you're live in the meeting if you'd like
to speak
no thanks if you can hear me i can't see
anything at all
okay thank you castlebally we'll get
some tech support to you
screen's gone all together thank you
we can hear you council molly
right
do we have any further counsellors that
would wish to speak please yes karen you
have counselor jeff lilly who's
indicating he would like to speak
counsellor lilly
so i cannot hear the don't know chair
whatsoever something wrong with the
microphone
uh but i cannot hear a word that's being
said
counselor lou will arrange some tech
support to to contact you
to help with your audio settings
is anyone else any further speakers
yes we have two further speakers
indicating councillor betty hill and
councillor jeremy kenyon
councillor hill
can you hear me yes better
right thank you well martin
avid all these things that's been said
about you
and over the past you and i have had one
or two arguments
but i think we've always genuinely
respected one another
and after all listening to all that's
been said
i'm really surprised that your party
hasn't taken you to that leadership
chair
and made you stop there because you will
be
very badly missed that's all i want to
say
thank you thank you
councillor kenyon thank you chair
yes everything's been said really i just
want to know
martin's depth of knowledge about every
part of this council
and the wider political environment we
work in whatever question i went to
martin with he would give me a detailed
and well thought
how to answer and point me in the right
direction she's a very high standard
for all of us to aspire to as thank you
martin
chair may i say something is councillor
huckabee
yes yes well i'd like to say a big thank
you
to martin i've known him for a long long
time
initially as a as a magistrate and by
doing that he persuaded me
uh to join the council he's been
a big help to me and a good friend
and like everyone else he will be very
very sadly missed
but i hope to see him at other venues
other than the council good luck martin
thank you council anjali foster
[Music]
thank you uh yeah i will keep it very
brief and just to note the
the some of the words have been said my
word of thank i was a
counselor in 2011 when martin started
his uh
career as leader of the conservative
group we were in opposition at the time
and uh yeah just to confirm some of the
words that were
said about the knowledge that martin has
about the rules and regulations of the
councils and
uh who to speak to in the council etc so
uh just to note my words of thanks for
for his
role in the council as well and also i
think uh
someone said i can't remember exactly
who it was
his dedication to the district and to
his role as a leader
of the council thank you
thank you
thank you i've already done my speech so
uh just remains for me to say thank you
for all those very kind words
um i didn't realize that people thought
so highly of me so
i've decided to change my mind and stay
no i'm just joking uh thank you very
much for your
very kind words and it really is
appreciated and some
[Music]
really wonderful things said and very
heartwarming and
it means a lot that it's come from such
a cross section of people from
from the chamber and particularly
councillor powell though that
range of um adjectives from the good old
days it sounded
um shows that i would now have to go
home and look them all up in a
dictionary
well thank you very much for those kind
words and thank you to everybody
um it means a lot thank you
thank you can we now go to item six the
election of leader of the council
thank you members we will now move to
the election of the leader of the
council can i invite nominations
from the floor
i'll do it so jeremy can you
indicate you wish to speak and so did
councillor charlotte cupid uh yes just
say i would i nominate
council alex dale as the leader
thank you councillor cooper
thank you um yeah i'd like to second um
counselor alex dale
as uh the leader of the council um i
think as we've just
paid tribute um councillor dale's got
big shoes to fill um but i know that
castledale's got the experience and
drive
to succeed for the administration but
also to the council um
you know we're entering a difficult time
of hopefully recovery from kovids
um and i hope that we can work together
first party but
um across the chamber to um
to work together and be able to
help our district back to recovery for
all our residents and businesses
i know that councillor dale has the
experience thrive commitment to do that
and to work for every resident
thank you are there any further
nominations
take it no all those in favor of
council alex dale can i can i just make
a comment please fall involved sorry
yes yes sorry it's it's just about the
point
i that i know we've said all them nice
things about martin and
and and albeit but from a council
perspective this is not a great time to
be changing leaders and
and changing portfolios and things like
that so
once we know we've got to have a new
leader for various reasons
uh we don't feel it's it's it's a good
time
and therefore we will will not be
supporting
or endorsing we don't we're not for
another name for it because we'll lose
but obviously
we're not endorsing the uh the change of
leadership at this time
okay that's the readers indicating her
wish to speak
okay am i able to speak calculated yes
yes i just want to make the point i i
completely agree with councillor nigel
barker and and
i have concerns obviously now martin has
been
um you know working really hard through
the coronavirus pandemic
um and obviously that has thrown a lot
of
chaos towards the council and so i agree
totally that we really shouldn't be
changing leader at this
time even though i do know martin has
got other commitments that he has
i do worry about the timing of this
change
thank you so
all those in favor of counselor alex
dale
if i might chair if we can go through
the procedure
um could every members please switch
their cameras off
so that i can ask who's going to vote in
favor thank you
off and then i will ask for all those in
favor to switch their cameras on
just to clarify all those members with
their camera on if you're wanting to
vote for
would you raise your hand so that we're
able to clearly see
okay could you switch your cameras off
please
and could all those who wish to vote
against
please put their cameras on and as the
government's manager says please put
your hand up
that's all those who wish to vote
against
please put your hand up if you wish to
vote against
i can see that sarah thanks can you
switch your cameras off please and
anybody who wishes to abstain
please will you switch your camera on
and put your hand up
that's anybody who wishes to abstain
that's three abstain yeah i agree
that's carried chairman
thank you
councillor dale
thank you chad i would uh just like to
say a few words
um taking on board some of the previous
comments
um it is a tremendous privilege and
honour uh to have been elected leader of
this great council
and i want to start by thanking in
particular the conservative group
for placing their support and trust in
me and also to reiterate
the thanks again once again to martin
everyone is right they
they are very big big shoes to phil
uh and i will i will pledge to this
council that i will always do my utmost
um to to do the right thing for this
district
um throughout the coronavirus pandemic
councillors from across the district
and across the political spectrum have i
believe shown some of the best of
northeast derbyshire
and by putting aside our political
differences and working constructively
together
particularly through our cross-party
viper meetings
we've helped to make tremendous
difference to the lives of our residents
and moving forward i know that there
will be times where we will disagree
and have some robust debates and i
expect some of the
uh motions may well later on today uh be
part of that but i'd
say to all opposition councillors at
noting the concerns that you've just
expressed
i hope that we can learn the lessons
from this pandemic and wherever possible
put aside our partisan barriers and work
together in the best interests of this
fantastic district
i'm immensely proud to have served in an
administration
which over the last year under martin's
leadership has frozen
council tax and achieved significant
savings for the taxpayer
by carrying out a line-by-line budget
review adopted an ambitious climate
change
action plan and made good progress in
doing our bit to reduce emissions
which we're now accelerating in light of
the changing ways of working
which have come out of covid we've
continued to fight inappropriate
development
and begun to impact the many challenges
within the planning system
left by the last administration we've
promoted neighborhood planning across
all our parishes so that communities
feel that they can have a say on
development within their areas
we've reformed our housing delivery arm
to ensure that we're the best possible
we're on the best possible footing to
improve our housing stock
regenerate our communities and promote
home ownership to the people of north
east derbyshire
we've hosted job fairs to help local
people find high quality local jobs
we've reduced our leisure subsidy while
continuing to drive
forward with improvements to our
facilities
we've won a town deal with potentially
up to 25 million pounds of government
funding to improve clay cross
and beginning now with a 500 000 pound
grant to get started
and we kick-started one public estate
studies in our northern settlements
to ensure we're able to access future
streams of funding to renovate our town
centres there
and most perhaps most importantly we've
coordinated and
delivered what i believe is one of the
most ambitious and comprehensive
covered 19 community and business
support programs
in the country the administration that i
will lead will continue to build on all
of these achievements
but our single highest priority will be
getting northeast derbyshire
back on its feet following the worst
impacts of the
pandemic this relentless focus on
recovery
will drive everything that we do whether
that's reintroducing services in new
ways to help keep residents safe
and ensure that as an organization we
benefit from the newer ways of working
or supporting businesses
to adjust to the new normal and ensuring
that north east alberta is a place where
businesses can establish themselves and
thrive
or draw driving economic growth and
regeneration schemes
across our district and tapping into
government funding to unlock key
developments
at every stage we will continue to be a
listening council
engaging with our residents and
businesses in a meaningful way
to ensure that every decision we take is
representative
of the needs we have all been elected to
serve
and should the virus strike again and we
find ourselves in a local or national
lockdown
we will be ready to jump into action
again to support the district
having learned key lessons from our
experiences
over the past few months thank you once
again for bestowing on me
the honor of becoming the leader of the
district council and i look forward to
working with you all
over the future thank you chair thank
you
council barca did you wish to say
something
no no
sorry i were writing all that down
okay thank you i'll go to item
seven can i now ask the leader to
confirm the council's deputy leader
and also confirm his cabinet for 20 20
21.
thank you i believe the documentation
has all been circulated giving the
the portfolio holders and structure of
each portfolio
and i'm happy to move that as a
recommendation
uh thank you chair thank you
uh if i might there's no need to move a
recommendation it is within the leader's
gift
thank you go to item nine
[Music]
oh automate changes to appointments to
committees
our advisory groups and outside bodies
thank you members we will now consider
the changes to appointments to
committees
advisory groups and outside bodies this
item was marked as to follow on your
agenda packs
do we have any further amendments and
can we approve these nominations
and have we got a mover and a seconder
from political parties who are
changing their seats
thank you cheryl i'm happy to move the
the amendments
made on our side chair i think council
shipment wants to speak
yeah council shipment thank you chair if
i could just make some
amendments to the lib dem allocations if
that's possible just move
if you can move me to planning counselor
hancock to standards so the other way
and take me off obviously standards
and pam windley as a substitute for
planning
and then i'll move the lid down
allocations on block please
we got a second uh i'll second that
chair
thank you
all right councillor cooper
thank you just to set in the
conservative
changes
can we can the monitoring officer please
lead us to the vote
will all those voting in favor please
switch on the cameras and put their
hands up
thank you very much can you switch your
cameras off anybody who wishes to vote
against
please switch your camera on and put
your hand up
yes i've got that chair thank you can
you switch your cameras off now please
and anybody who wishes to
abstain please switch your camera on and
put your hand up
okay
thank you we will now move to
on to changes to appointments of the
chairs and vice chairs
this item was also marked to follow on
your agenda packs
can we approve these changes and have we
got a mover and a seconder
can the monitoring officer please lead
us in the vote
thank you
we need a mover and a seconder first
councillor renick is indicating she
would like to speak and count for oscar
gomez rini
yeah i'd like to uh close those please
second chair second that
that case could all those in favor
please put the cameras on and lift their
hands
i've got that sarah thank you could you
could all those who wish to vote against
please put their cameras on
and put their hands up and everybody
else switch the camera off please
so anybody wish to vote against
thank you sorry i'll say there's nobody
indicating they want to vote against
and could anybody who wishes to abstain
please switch on their camera and lift
the hand
thank you yeah that's carried
thank you thank you
under the next item public participation
there is one question from a member of
the public
just to remind members there is no
debate allowed on public questions
the question this afternoon is from
antoday
to the portfolio holder for
transformation and climate change to
council jeremy kenyon
mr could you please answer your question
to the portfolio holder
yeah um good afternoon councillors
um i'm going to read an abbreviated
version because the
question i've sent in i'm afraid is too
long for the time allowed
so um i'm going to cut out the quotes
that are from
um national local policy but you can
read it i
imagine in the agenda or the minutes
our uk government has made a commitment
in legislation to achieve net zero
greenhouse gas emissions by 2050
if we are to meet this target we need a
rapid reduction in the carbon emissions
associated with household energy
consumption
in a report last year the committee on
climate change
warned that the uk's legally binding
climate change targets
will not be met without the near
complete elimination of greenhouse gas
emissions
from uk buildings the key role of
planning
in reducing greenhouse gas emissions is
acknowledged in the northeast derbyshire
climate change action plan 2019-2030
the northeast derbyshire local plan
2014-34
includes a requirement that new
developments promote
energy efficiency to a sustainable level
the sustainability appraisal of the
northeast derbyshire local plan
february 2018 includes a statement on
the role of local authorities in
reducing greenhouse gas emissions
these national and local documents all
include statements on the role planning
must play
in reducing the production of greenhouse
gases through minimizing energy
consumption
north east derbyshire council currently
have plans in place for large areas of
future new housing development
including in the clay cross area up to
824 dwellings
on the bywater site and up to 700 on the
avenue site by 2034.
on average the generally expected and
acceptable lifespan of a new house
is at least 60 years and some sources
believe should be up to
100 years in practice it is frequently
much longer
if houses currently in the planning
stage including those in northeast
derbyshire
are likely to last towards the end of
this century
and some of them well belong beyond they
need to be achieving zero
carbon or passive health standards if
they are to meet the requirements of the
uk
net zero greenhouse gas targets
given that houses built now are unlikely
to undergo substantial
refurbishment before 2050 it
is imperative that they are built to a
zero carbon standard now
with this in mind can the councillor
please describe the following
what efforts have been made to engage
and work with local housing developers
of zero carbon homes
and can the councillor explain exactly
what percentage of the houses currently
planned for the bywater and avenue sites
will achieve net zero carbon emissions
level six using the standard set in the
code for sustainable homes
or be built to passive house standard
and what efforts have been made to
ensure the highest possible levels of
on-site energy production
electrical and thermal on new buildings
thank you council canyon but
for your question uh currently only
small numbers of net zero houses or
passive
um houses are being built anywhere in
the uk
and there are none in the first phases
of the avenue and by water sites um
the net zero for a house doesn't mean
zero emissions
it means that the total energy consumed
by the house is balanced against the
total energy
produced by on house generation
unfortunately the energy consumption is
mainly in the cold months and the energy
production
is mainly in the warm months so
extensive off-house energy production
will still be required for our housing
in winter
even if every house was net zero um
district heating offers some better
long-term possibilities
and there are interesting options such
as energy from old coal mines
particularly in the avenue area or using
waste heat from other processes
and we're investigating several
possibilities
the question rightly refers to the long
lifetimes of houses being built today
and i share the view that um 100 years
will be better than 60.
however any on-house production
equipment such as solar panels
is only going to have a short lifetime
compared to the life of the house
typically equipment will be used for 20
to 30 years
before needing replacement allowing more
efficient solutions to be introduced
over time
the fundamental way to reduce emissions
from housing
is to reduce the energy needed to heat
and cool a house
which is down to better design and
insulation
and other things such as reducing water
usage that is why building standards for
new homes focus on these elements and
our planners
spend considerable time working with
developers setting out expectations
in our planning policies reviewing
planning applications and
ensuring energy efficiency requirements
are met and exceeded
we also have a clear need to maximize
emission cuts for the available resource
the additional build cost for a house
built to level 6 standards
compared to current regulations is
around 20 000
pounds but housing already built today
will still be the vast majority of
housing
in 2050 so while it may be mundane
installing high efficiency heating and
insulation but doing that in older
housing delivers very high emissions
reductions
and that is our main goal so one key
focus will be making sure
that our residents use the recent
government initiative to offer
homeowners
up to five thousand pounds to improve
their insulation and boilers in their
homes
and that goes up to ten thousand pounds
for people on low income
another will be to continue our program
of improving council housing stock
by our external wall insulation internal
internal insulation boiler replacement
and indeed whole house replacement to
current standards
so our focus is and has to be on
achieving the biggest reductions
and that is where we're directing our
efforts thank you
thank you so then would you like to ask
a supplementary question
please yes um
yeah in terms of my supplementary
question i'm going to ask whether
the council's um saw
legal planning guidance to establish
how the highest standards of energy
efficiency
that can be required from housing
developments
um could be achieved within the building
regulations
framework rather than um settling for
the minimum
amount that developers can um
can produce but i'm i'm just going to
point out councillor that you haven't
actually asked
answered my first question in terms of
what efforts have been made to engage
and work with local housing developers
of zero carbon homes
as i said we're putting our efforts
where we believe they're going to be
most effective for achieving our shared
goal
of reducing total emissions um
the um have we sought legal
um guidance our planners definitely are
very aware
of the the legal requirements and if you
read our client plan in fact they refer
to them
must be half a dozen times saying how
they are limited by the legal framework
they have to operate in
and uh changing that is obviously way
beyond
uh this district council's um
abilities we are limited by the national
requirements and indeed
the um the level six standard uh was
uh explicitly council great were
explicitly told they could not
um force adoption of that or even
require it
uh i think that goes back to 2015 when
that decision was made
so in practice we are limited by
um national policy i would also say that
the difference in cost between level 4
and level 6
is substantial and we have to balance
the need to
produce affordable homes for our
population our growing population
against
the extra efficiencies that you get
between level four and level six
for example what i would also say though
is we're very much looking forward to
the upcoming new
future home standard because that will
significantly increase
the efficiency of new buildings um and
should reduce the carbon footprint by
estimates variable between 60 and 70
percent
so we're we're very much interested in
that becoming
part of the uh the national um
regulation if you like because that will
give a long-term benefit on the new
housing as well
thank you councillor kenyon
thank you that concludes the public
questions so we'll move on to item 11.
can i now invite the scrutiny chairs to
present the scrutiny annual report
20 19 20. thank you
council angelique foster's indicating
her wish to speak
council foster thank you so obviously
i'm only the chair of the organization
scrutiny so
i wouldn't present the whole report but
if i may
uh just to touch on what we have been
doing as
a organization scrutiny
so we this year we undertook a review of
our health
and well-being framework we're keen to
look
into the key measures uh already in
place
within the organization but also to
identify
any key concerns that might be existent
throughout
the authority as it is customary we
reviewed a number of documents
and presentations including the current
health and wellbeing framework the
employee assistance program
the sickness information and the health
and wellbeing
survey results we also carried out a
number of interviews with managers
and carried out walkabouts at mill lane
and eckington
depot where members of the scrutiny
committee were able to converse directly
with the employees we have concluded our
evidence gathering
as the report here says but we will be
finalizing our findings at our next
meeting
in august due to the delays that caused
by the covet-19 lockdown
circumstances so at this point
i would like to thank the staff for
their continued commitment
and hard work in the face of
unprecedented
challenging circumstances and i know we
are not usually
supposed to single out one particular
member of staff
but i'd like to council to note my
thanks personal thanks
to sue vereman for her excellent
professionalism
and efficacy in making sure that chairs
receive
proper support and guidance throughout
but
also that the scrutiny function was able
to continue
obviously the current circumstances
required a certain degree of flexibility
from
all stakeholders but we are also already
looking forward
and my colleagues and i agree that
health and well-being
will still be a key interest in the
coming year
and we will continue to review how the
coping 19
aftermath is affecting the organization
as a whole
as a workplace and also we want to play
our part in bringing
improvements wherever needed for the
benefit of the council as a whole
thank you
thank you councillor tate
yes thank you uh i'm pleased to present
this report about the community's
community scrutiny committee these are
the finest conclusions and recommend
recommendations from its review into
parking so full review taken in all the
areas effect
affecting parking within the district
during the review period the committee
heard from a number of officers
stakeholders as well as writing to local
as well as writing to and consulting
town councils and conducting interviews
committee heard how much parking impacts
on the residents of north east
derbyshire from planning applications
bin collections emergency response
vehicles
and the use of leisure facilities the
report contains a number of
recommendations which will fill
which we feel will make parking within
the district better for the residents
again like council foster said i'd like
to thank all the members of this group
committee for the hard work throughout
the year
which has made the review an enjoyable
process and again i would also like to
extend a special thanks to the scrutiny
manager suvirman for hard work and input
which has made the review possible
thank you thank you councillor
hutchinson
thank you chair um i took over in april
as chair of the global scrutiny
committee
and as we anticipate the imminent
arrival of both growth and tourism
strategies we as a committee are
over-minded
in the interim we should feeding ideas
uh to the director of growth and
economic development
to assist with the finalization of the
strategies
um i'd like to uh thank the members of
the growth school for the committee on
all sides of the political spectrum
uh for contributing so positively and
like uh councillor tate and councillor
foster have said
silverman for her work
thank you should we move the report
uh is there a second
could i speak chain give a report for
the audit and corporate governance
yes councillor foster thank you chair
um most of this is on page 20 and 29 of
the pack
i'm not going to read out the whole lot
but i'll just summarize
the audit committee met four times last
year i'm pleased to report that all the
key governance and financial documents
that were detailed in our work plan in
the program
were reviewed by the committee this
included signing off the audited
statements of accounts
reviewing the council's budgets and
monitoring reports
considering reports from the external
and internal audit
and discussing any matters arising
reviewing performance
which this year also included
considering the 2019
and to 23 council plan we also reviewed
the sit perform
product corruption tracker survey uh
from the charter institute of public
finance
and the third prevention measures that
we have in place
the committee's view was clear on this
we should continue to support a zero
tolerance approach
towards fraud finally the committee was
also keen to fulfill its scrutiny role
during the year and held a number of
discussions on ict
provision those recommendations led
from the committee to establish new
reporting protocols between the joint
ict committee
and the council lastly like the other
councillors the other chairs i'd like to
thank all the committee members
for the work and taking part in the
committee it's been an enjoyable
committee to work on
uh and also all the officers for their
support
in particular jain ethic so thank you
very much
thank you are you moving the uh
recommendations
i'm happy to move jeff if not else
then a second thank you
are there any comments
no indications to speak to
thank you
does the scrutiny chairs have a right to
reply
sorry there's no questions right
we will now move to the vote can the
monitoring officer please lead us in the
vote
thank you chair could all those in favor
please switch their cameras on and lift
their hands please
thank you could anybody who wishes to
vote against please switch their camera
on and lift their hand
and finally anybody who wishes to
abstain
[Music]
only abstentions
thank you thank you chair that's carried
thank you and we now go to
uh item 12. i can confirm that we have
one question
submitted under procedure rule nine two
and that
is from now council nigel barker
directed to councillor charlotte cupid
portfolio holder for environment that's
lebarka
thank you yeah
it's it's in your pack but whilst we
welcome the fact that the local plan has
been
unpaused can councillor cupid update the
council
as to where we are in the process and
give us a timetable
as to when the plan will be adopted
thank you
okay
down to the cooper
chair um thank you to council marcus for
his question
um i think a question on the local plan
must be mean a little bit of normality
is resuming at least
um you're aware of the correspondence on
pausing the draft
plan to proceed to the next
consultations and you may be aware of
the correspondence during march and
april
this rightly delayed consultations due
to coding 19
as it wouldn't have been appropriate or
possible to conduct consultations during
that time
uh however i can confirm that the
initial targeted and technical
consultation to update the housing land
supply and totally focused on that has
now taken place
over june and the consultation responses
should be on the website soon
under the examination pages and the
inspectors now considering these
responses i understand
along with some additional work on
updated house household questions
nationally
i understand she will then set out the
next steps for the examination
the council remains under examination
and so it's therefore dependent on the
inspector to set the timetable in the
process
so we're awaiting that this will include
a future timetable
and for the wider public consultation on
the main modifications
to the draft plan and updates will be on
the website as soon as possible
thank you thank you
councillor barker flamenco question
let me just reach you welcome uh
i say them really colors are like that
really uh
it's a bit bit underwhelmed with that
and i accept the the coldwood things
sort of slow sort of spamming works
uh seriously i wasn't trying to be
clever with this and i know i keep
banging on about it
it's uh or even trying to play
politics with it it's i i'm genuinely
just trying to find out
some sort of timeline as to when the
plan will be adopted really because
people keep asking me and i'm sure
they're asking you
uh and just and i know it's all in the
hands and the inspector and they're
doing all this stuff
but in your opinion do you think it will
be adopted
in 2000 this year do you think it will
be adopted this year
is my question just just uh just uh
a good reaction uh charlotte
thank you council cooper
thank you chair um i'm sorry councillor
barker i really can't give
a sort of specific timetable because
it's up to the inspector we have been
delayed by
kovid19 um and there is also the key
thing that we have to have
the consultation the big public
consultation on the main modifications
i don't think it's right so i can't and
i won't preempt the next public
consultation on the main modifications
uh or the inspector's decision on that
and her final report i know
you may not have been keen on this as a
previous labor administration but the
whole point of a consultation is that
you listen to residents
and to the people you're consulting
which is a council we're keen to do
we've said that all here today so i hope
we can do that and then the inspector
will take those views or points
uh into account in her next steps and
then we can move on but it
i'm sorry not to be able to give you a
specific answer council barca but it is
up to the inspector to decide the final
timetable
um but i can assure you that we are
progressing to move that forward as
quickly as possible
and that's why we've done the initial
targeted consultation and we're now
looking to do the main one
as quick as possible so i hope that
helps at least that we are
pushing um forward with the next stages
as quick as we possibly can thank you
thank you that concludes today's
question session
and we'll now move on to item 13.
thank you members in accordance with
council procedure rule 10
i confirm i can confirm that we have
three motions to consider
i now invite council hancock to move
motion a on the agenda
thank you chair um actually in light of
in light of this one because there has
been correspondence which has been
taking place today so
purely for notes for the minute um
because
this this motion has actually been
coming forward for months and it's been
held up by coving and the conversion on
to remote monitoring so we've been able
to work with officers in the meantime
and the legal team have actually
confirmed to me
literally at lunch time today that they
are actually able to put this through
so we don't need to do it i didn't email
the monitoring officer but i suspect in
all honesty she hasn't even had time to
to access the email because it was
around half 12 today
so i am withdrawing the motion but for
the sake of the notes i could thank
kevin chilito the legal officer who has
put a heck of a lot of work in
but also because we have so much in this
council which goes on
playing party politics i want to
actually pay my thanks
to the various members from all of the
political groups who have actually also
been quite productive with this motion
as well i'm quite positive and
supporting of it
so the motion is withdrawn so it's
purely a note at this stage but
if we can know the various things
thank you councilloran park we'll now
move to the second motion
i'm about counselor shipment to move
motion b
thank you chair um i will just first
firstly point out before i start because
i'm sure this will be thrown at me in a
second there are no plans as far as i
know
that there's going to be any raising of
cancer allowances or special
responsibility allowance so i just want
to make that absolutely clear
but this motion is to preempt anything
that
or any attempts in future which may come
from a group or
an independent remuneration panel about
raising such allowances
now it pleases me to move this motion
and enshrine that the councils are truly
in it together with our communities by
holding off any debate about raising
councillors basic and special
responsibility allowances until at least
2022
it probably will it really should go on
longer to be honest given the fact that
i mean the outgoing leader said in one
of his recent communications to all
councillors and i believed him when he
said it that this
the the covenant 19 crisis has caused
unprecedented um
strain on the council's finances and the
tough decisions that had to be made so
on the expenditure
and making sure that we're not over
overspending and we're curtailing any
additional expenses we would have
perhaps made
um that we now can't because obviously
the strain on the finances
it therefore makes sense to me that the
public know that during the next two
years
we are not even going to consider
entertaining a debate on
raising councillors basic special
responsibility
allowances i mean how many times have we
heard
people say and just off the cuff remarks
about how they think counselors do this
job
just to serve themselves well this is an
opportunity for us all
to show that we listen to them and that
we actually
care what they've got to say and that
we're all willing to
kibbush any any potential pay increases
for us as counsellors
now there's when i've i posted that i
submitted this motion
i i'd read comments this is someone from
killermarsh that said
be good if they agree but i doubt it now
that's what we're dealing with there was
another one from uh from uh lady in
wingwood who said good luck with that
one
never known any council to delay a pay
rise it's usually the first thing they
do
well hopefully we can all come together
today and make this commitment to our
residents in northeaster
that we're not going to entertain any
debate on raising councils or special
responsibility allowances
so please support this motion its
entirety or
if it's going to be amended extend the
date beyond 2022.
thank you
is there a second though
[Music]
i'm happy to second chair and i'll
reserve my right to speak until later in
the debate please
okay
sorry is there anyone who wishes to
speak
there are no indications to speak yeah i
will uh
come in to speak then if there's no one
else who wishes to speak first
council pam wendy's indicating she'd
like to speak as is council paul parkin
councilwood
can you hear me now yes thank you sorry
yeah and i totally agree with this i
support ross
with this there's a lot of people out
there who are a lot
worse off than what we are and um
i'd like to see this motion moved thank
you
thank you
councillor parking
sorry chair my camera came on by
accident councillor dale
thank you chair um just to start by
saying that local
conservatives have a proud history of
campaigning to keep the cost of our
politics low
um when labour took control of the
county council in 2013
i understand that one of their first
actions was to give their cabinet
members a pay rise of 12
and when we took control in 2017 one of
our first actions
was their point of order please i would
remind
councillor dale that uh under rule 12.4
that we are here to discuss the motion
it's not for party political campaigning
i i i think i'm entitled to refer to
examples of uh
in relation to uh allowances council
councillor dale the the the rule is
quite specific you are to to debate the
question
i think i think council hancock i'll
look to the chair um
for advice on this
may i proceed check carry on counselors
and recently in bowls over um where the
district council there has one of the
highest
um allowances for a district council of
its size it was conservative councillors
that put forward a motion to cut those
allowances to more normal rates
but the simple fact is that this motion
isn't necessary for two significant
reasons
one which uh councillor shipman alluded
to himself
there are absolutely no plans to
increase allowances under this
administration
um it's clear to me that sir the
proposer and secondary of this motion
have basically created a straw man in
order to try and claim victory for doing
absolutely nothing and perhaps the more
fundamental point though
from my perspective is that actually
whatever the rate
morally it isn't correct for councillors
to be setting their own
their own allowances it's a slippery
slope in my eyes that that
could lead to the erosion of trust in
local government
in the same way that mps don't set their
own pay and rightly so
i don't believe that councillors should
um quite rightly it's for an independent
remuneration panel to decide
the last one presented recommendations
to council as i understand it in 2017
and is therefore due to present in the
next couple of years
we believe that that is the right
process to be to be followed
it should be independent of the council
benchmarking suggests that our
allowances are actually fairly low for
an authority
of our sized and based on the size of
our sizes of our awards
however should the next irp recommend an
egregious increase
in allowances and i certainly hope it
won't then the council still holds the
right to refuse it on block
and equally every single member in this
chamber
has the right to forego their allowances
or indeed any increase in allowances
and for these reasons the conservative
group will not be supporting the motion
thank you thank you councillor barker
yeah thank you chad
again while we've got a lot of sympathy
we what's in the motion and i'm sure
uh it's something that'll that'll come
back again there's other principles as
well and i think
alex has referred to some there that uh
it's about setting your old pay and one
thing another
uh and also uh i'm sure there's nobody
on that on this panel on this this
screen in front of me that's doing it
for money
uh bought insane breath we don't want it
we want it to be remunerated at the
level
where he's not bringing people off being
counselors
i mean some people can afford it there's
others
that little struggle on the allowances
that we get
and i think if we you unilaterally just
say
we don't want it then that that's you
cutting
we can all individually uh forgoer
allowances
we we can donate it to other things uh i
mean i've put money into the
uh the food things well that i don't
want no
no rates for that that's my choice but i
think we've got to be careful
and i know which one we we're going to
get twisted round on the
facebook or whatever uh that we're
looking after ourselves
for its same breath it's it's it's
independently set
that other people uh of we've worked in
this position
and so therefore on that principle we'll
be voting against this
thank you council parker councillor
pickering
yes uh thank you thank you chair um
just to reiterate um some of councillor
barker's comments
and uh surprising to myself some
counselor dales as well
i didn't think we'd ever be doing that
and of course
uh council's pay is independently set as
it is
uh for uh mps um and that's
the quite right and proper review
process and it takes it away from what
councillor shipman's trying to do which
is
make political capital of it he said
he's been talking to people in killer
marsh yes he'll be going around with
this emotive subject of
let's take money away from councillors
well
it's not just as simple as that we don't
know whether councillors can afford that
or not we don't know how much
that council's allowance contributes to
income we wouldn't want to take it away
from the paid workforce
we wouldn't want to take it away from
people who are
in paid employment for voluntary
organizations
why do we want to put pinpoint and
target councils in particular
i think it's cheap political gain we've
got a proper
process for councillors pay and
and that's where it should rest and
that's what we should be supporting
and i won't be supporting this uh
amendment for those
uh this motion for those reasons and i
hope the rest of my group won't as well
thank you chair thank you councillor
pickling
can i now ask council hancock uh who
deserves this right to speak
thank you chair appreciate that i would
actually just like to pick up on
on councillor pickering's point and and
appoint the
sir councillor i think he might have
been barca so i don't want him falsely
thoughts to name someone um
[Music]
i think we all do this job because we
want to do the best
so i think we take out this whole
concept that motions are put forward for
political game they're not
they're put forward irrespective whether
they're buyers by the conservatives by
the labor group by the independents
they're put forward because it's
something we believe in i don't know
whether councillor pickering has got the
wrong end of the stick
in the way he was reading the motion
um no point does this motion suggest
that
allowances be taken away from members it
follows up on
effectively crystallizing what council
dale said which is
so i'm quite surprised at some of his
comments actually um
that we simply forego for the current
term any any allowance that is put
forward to us i mean i remember having
this discussion in 2017 and
i made exactly the same point there we
it it is an independent review
we don't have to accept it and this is
simply saying
actually let's formalize that now rather
than do it then so
i fully support the motion it is there
with the best of intentions and i think
it it's immoral of counsellors to
suggest otherwise
um and and i will stand by that that so
that comment there so i i'm fully happy
to say
to second this i think it's the right
thing for us to do i think it's a
morally
it's a moral issue and i think given the
fact we are i mean
i'm i'm not gonna make a political gain
of it i i raised concerns when we did
the budget and the freezing the council
tax at that point in time none of us
could have foreseen the events that have
happened
it's escalated out of all so i think
we we do need to play our part and and
the the reality is this is going to be a
relatively small financial part but i do
think it's it's
the appropriate and the moral thing to
do
thank you councillor shipman do you wish
to exercise your right of reply
yes if i country thank you um
it always makes me laugh when i when
counselor dale likes to give us a nice
speech about our other members of this
council are
making political points and are trying
to score political capital i mean every
speech is
given tonight is out of popular labor
the labour councillors and the labour
administrations from this council and
other councils
so i mean where he gets this idea from
the other councillors
are doing that i mean every motion i
have put on this council
it's been with good intentions to try
and improve the council
try and make sure that this council is
doing good in this in our communities
not
i mean i'm literally getting no gain
from this that's what that's what the
motion is saying that i'm getting no
gain
if we could all support this then and
crystallize what counselor dale is
saying because he has admitted that
there is no plans too
therefore if we were to pass this it
mitigates any concerns that council of
piccary
and councillor barker had because
ultimately if councillor dell's
words are true no although no counsellor
regardless of what their background is
regardless of what their working
conditions are
or benefit conditions they won't be
getting a pay rise if you list if you
believe
councillor dale's words to be absolutely
true
during this covered 19 crisis
unemployment in this district is almost
triples
to eight percent so there's people that
are
going without whilst we're here um
saying that we're not going to rule out
and this is what the motion says we are
not it's to rule out the
discussion on raising it for councillors
we were to pass it
it crystallized what councilor dale's
going to say we will not be considering
any pay increase for councillors
it doesn't say anything about taking
money away and i would agree
we shouldn't be at this point in time
taking anything away
but what it does say is there will be no
increases
for members of this council and i would
just like to reiterate that this is with
good intentions and i think that this
sends a strong message to people in
northeast derbyshire
that we are listening to them that we do
stand with them whilst they're all
struggling to get
back to work after furlough that we're
saying we're not going to consider any
pay increases
it's as simple as that there's not we're
not taking anything away and i would
urge
all councillors to think for themselves
and individually and not follow a whip
when it comes to decisions like this
which ultimately should be a personal
conscious choice
and not one that a political party is
making thank you chair
thank you and the monitoring officer now
lead us to the vote
all those in favor of the motion please
turn on their cameras
and lift their hands
thank you will all those who are against
the motion please turn
on your cameras and lift your hands
chair i can't turn on my video anymore
you've blocked it um
right you're voting against
yeah thanks
yes almost block mine as well
okay so
everybody voted who wishes to
this is the vote against the motion
finally if there is anybody who wishes
to abstain can you please switch on your
camera
chair the motion is defeated
okay
we will now move to the third motion for
consideration today
i now invite councillor windley to move
motion c
councillor windley
council notes the first class service
delivered by its employees and
members throughout the program 19 year
emergency
but it always strives to improve on its
own performance
that those individuals and families who
are suffering with
or caring for early stage dementia
experience challenges over and above
those
faced by many others in the community
that often these early stage cases are
not receiving support
from gps and adult social care
council results to thank all of our
staff and members for their excellent
work
to proactively support the chair in her
work with alzheimer's research uk
by undertaking a district-wide survey
to identify the additional support
needed by these early stage
dementia patients and their families
carers
and to use our health and wellbeing
remit
to implement the findings
can we have a seconder
i'm happy to second this one chair um i
think it's
it's a case of highlighting actually the
excellent job
that everyone does in in terms of this
and and
again credit to yourself for um for the
work that you're doing with the with the
alzheimer's research
group we know that social care is very
much a county issue
but it's it's become and i think
probably because of the situation that
we've had over the last few months
very very acute how many people are
actually caught in this
this position before then and also the
the impact that it has on carers and
conversations that we've been having
with people who
who are caring for those with dementia
um
early onset dementia particularly is
that
there's very little support in place to
them there's also very little chance of
them living their normal life
and i think it's surprising how much of
a change and
when one has a baby you have antenatal
classes there's absolutely no kind of
equivalent when suddenly
somebody that you care for is changing
and changing in ways that they may not
even realize themselves
so we have the health and well-being
we need to look into it the problem is
at this point the needs of everyone are
so diverse
we need to actually go out and source
what they are i mean that
i've spoken with different with
different carers some of them like
little care support groups others
actually want to just
escape from it and allow to and have an
hour
occasionally to do what they want to do
for themselves as a person that they've
given up
so it isn't a one-size-fits-all thing we
need to actually go out there
investigate what people want and then
what we can actually implement within
our remit
so i'm happy to second this on behalf of
councillor windley i think it's an
important need
that we've got in our district and uh
and
i hope the members will support it and
if they've got any amendments and
please please actually amend it in a
positive way so that we can show
how dedicated we are as a council to
people who are in this position
thank you thank you
councillor mark foster
yeah thank you chair uh yeah when i look
at this motion there's a lot i can agree
with
in this motion my apologies if my mic is
crackling
there's a lot i can agree with in this
uh it starts off by
talking about the first class service
delivered by employees and members
throughout the coming 19
which is separate uh to me to speaking
about
alzheimer's and dementia
it also goes on to say that it always
strives to improve on its performance
and that those individuals and families
who are suffering from
i've always been told that it's how we
should express it is
living with living without caring for
early stage dementia
and so on it then makes a fourth note
where it speaks of that often these
early stages are
not receiving support from gps or adult
social care
we're moving from praising there we're
mixing up praising
our staff at the district for what
they've done which is
right and proper and i think we'd all
all agree with that
here in that fourth note we're speaking
about we're speaking about criticizing
and it is criticism for our gps the nhs
and for adult social care
our county so for me i could support the
first three
but not that fourth note so that's the
first thing
secondly it goes on to two resolutions
uh to thank all of our staff and members
yes we'd like to thank them we thank
them many times already and i'd like to
continue in that thanks
also to proactively support the chair in
our work in alzheimer's research
uk yes but not to undertake a
district-wide survey
the reason for this is if we agree to
this here and now
there's been no discussion to priorities
what else the council have got on what
else
officers have got on if you're wanting
to if the
if uh pam windley counselor pam when
they would like to
uh put forward the idea of a survey
district-wide survey
the proper method for that should be
through
the scrutiny committees and as most of
you will know
all of the scrutiny committees have got
health and well-being
uh within their terms of reference and
that's where it should go
before you decide to take it before that
committee puts it forward and decides to
do that
uh survey and make a year's worth of
work if it takes a year
you've got time to discuss it you've got
half an hour you've got an hour
and the check can make time for that
that's where this should go it should
not be at full council so here
we've got lots of positive things
about the council we've got thanks that
we strive to improve on its performance
and mixed in with that
we got criticism for the nhs and for the
counting
now this is the wrong time to be
criticizing
these other organizations so i can
support the first uh the first three
points
not that fourth point of the criticism
for the gp's adult social care
i could also uh resolve to thank members
of staff for their excellent work
and when it comes to that second
resolution to proactively support the
chair inner work
yes right up to the point of where it
says uk
full stop and falling from that what i
would like to do
is put that as an amendment so
i would like to propose that amendment
that we accept if it's clear to the
officers
those first three parts not that fourth
part
about gps and adult social care that we
do resolve to thank staff
and the second part of the resolution to
proactively support
up to uk full stop and that'd be my
and what i would like to add as well we
speak about not playing politics
this is the worst sort of schoolyard
politics
it's student politics and it belongs on
a student campus mixing support for our
staff
uh with criticism of other organizations
and that's exactly how i see it
so from now on i'd like to see things
like this go to committee and not to
waste my
time here thank you
jim i make a point of personal
explanation for council foster because i
think he's
he's misunderstood 0.4 so if i could
actually clarify that
before any member goes to discuss any
point
quite gone go ahead thank you yeah
council of foster has taken that as
being a criticism it absolutely isn't
it's highlighting the fact that um very
often
and particularly with people who who are
in early stage dementia
they don't actually recognize that they
have an issue and getting them to even
go to the doctor
and getting adult social care involved
is
a tr is a as an issue in itself so it
absolutely
is not a criticism of those agencies at
all it's saying that simply then not be
able to be accessed
so they're not receiving support from
them so i would just like that point of
clarity
before any comments are kind of made
further which which take
that impression because it absolutely
isn't chair
my comments stand on my amendment stands
would you like to propose thank you
chair
council shipment you need a second
it's council foster council foster who
needs a seconder for his amendment
yes cheryl second thanks uh
for kenyan uh i thoroughly support the
thrust of this motion
that detail such as requiring a survey
into one particular issue
in isolation from all other claims on
council resource
it's just an unnecessary micromanagement
of day-to-day council business and
i don't think it's appropriate for that
level of detail to be in a
council motion and i'd also say that
point four in the notes
uh whatever the intention it does read
as a criticism and i think it should be
removed
so i second the amendment
thank you coming now
can we now debate the amendment sure
okay i've been waiting to speak for the
last five minutes
before before mark poster
if you're going to ignore me then i'll
leave the meeting all together
ignoring you council ale i've got your
name down
could could if you want to speak
can you speak now yes i do like to speak
as you're all aware or most of you i
have some
input into this conversation and i'm not
interested in party political arguments
between the lib dems and the
conservatives
i don't want to know about that i do
know
that when you're diagnosed with early
dementia in your 40s
the fact first fact is getting somebody
or some people to recognize
that you have got dementia and it's not
a migraine and what have you that you're
suffering from
and because they're in the early 40s
people don't know don't even want to
know
that the mind have dementia so you pass
from pillar to post
and pat you know yourself i ended up
with our julie
at derby to get somebody to listen to
what was going on
and it was there not chesterfield and
not
local it was there that they recognized
she'd got early onset dementia and from
then it you know yourself
it's a downward spiral and i feel
you know i'm not interested in party
political
uh arguments on this i will be voting
for it
because i want uh i want people to
recognize
that young very young people
get dementia
thank you counselor hell
can we go back to councillor shipman on
the amendment
thank you chair if i may um if it's
possible and counselor
foster agrees if we can amend his
amendment um
to say to to reword the line which he
thinks is a criticism
so it actually says often the patience
i mean you won't decide if you wish but
often the patients through no fault of
any service provider
um are unable to get the diagnosis
for dementia from
you know so so it actually so it
specifies that in there that actually
people aren't like
councillor hill says people are actually
going undiagnosed through no fault of
anybody else's purely because of the
the way the system functions because
obviously the younger you are people
will assume it's a migraine
or may think it's something else and
won't necessarily by default
go towards it be it being alzheimer's or
or onset dementia um and
where he wants to remove the uh a bit
about the
um to having the um
survey for for us to agree in principle
that a survey is happening but for it to
go to one of the scrutiny committees
to hammer out what that survey looks
like
and what it is it's trying to achieve um
and obviously then it will go to a
scrutiny
permitted for them to deal with as they
wish
um so it doesn't remove or negate any
part of the motion but
actually clarifies uh and hopefully gets
the agreement of
everybody in the um in the chamber um
i fully support the motion and its
intent but i do agree uh
the wording could slightly be changed to
remove that ambiguity around it
potentially criticizing somebody or you
know
what it is it's trying to achieve
because there needs to be some outcome
to this motion
and i think that the survey is that
outcome
but i do agree with councillor foster
that there needs to be a process leading
up to that
to ensure that the survey is celebrated
and scrutinized so that it can actually
achieve something
thank you
do we have a secondary
for the amended amendment no chairman um
you can only deal with one amendment
at once unless councillors foster and
kenyan agree to change it
do you want me to come back now chair is
that that suitable
other are there other people to speak
uh angelique uh pasta wishes i'll come
back up
thank you i think uh the comments were i
was going to make we moved on since then
so
i'm happy to uh just not speak at that
point
thank you thank you
[Music]
yeah i can come right now if that's
suitable uh no those are
put forward by council shipment no i
would like that fourth part taking out
we're not splitting heads we're taking
that out that is why what i'm proposing
as for the survey uh i take your point
about hammering out um
the the details of the survey at um
at the committee level yes i know where
you're coming from that we commit to it
here and the
uh and there they hammer out the details
that's not what i'm proposing what i'm
saying is
when you when you're dealing with
something like this and committing to a
survey
the commitment to the survey must be at
uh the committee level they will decide
what priorities they've got
who can look into it what office of time
they've got on all of that
there's other things going on within the
council and it's there where the
priorities
are set it's you might want to set it
here but i don't think we should and
that's why my amendment stands as i've
already
uh put it forward so take it to one of
the committees
and they're not just hammering out the
details of the survey but before you get
to that stage
discuss what else is on the agenda for
that particular committee
so it stands and i know there may be
will as soon as people finish speaking
chair i'd like to put this to the vote
and put this to bed
thank you uh councillor barker
thank you yeah i think i've got it
obviously we we we were going to vote
for the original motion because of the
sentiments
in it and and what people have said well
i think
the amendment to the amendment and i
understand what you're saying what
council of foster
i've i've sort of got all that uh and i
think
the the principle of of of going to a
scrutiny
is right so i think
that that we could support uh the
amendment
for out where i'd also like to put in
i've been listening to
the councillor and council of windley
who've got personal experience of this
that whatever committee that goes to
whether whichever its communities or or
whatever
that those two councillors are invited
as well
because they've got the background bit
sounds of it as as where
some of the uh the holes are in the
system
and and i think we're all wanting the
same thing
for the system to be better so that
people don't slip through the net and
and can be diagnosed earlier and
everything like that
i'd also like to make the point that
while we're thanking staff
and i agree it is a bit mixed up the
motion between
council staff and and social work staff
but i think we should be thanking them
all
from for what we've we've we've been
through over the last
four or five months and and now i'd sort
of put in
into the debate or the thing that that
going forward we don't uh we don't have
all the jobs
the staff you know we keep up the
staffing levels in social care
and in our uh councils
i'm not saying we put that into this
motion i'm just making the point
that we're good at thanking people and
we're good at making gestures
but when when all this has settled
somebody some i'm fearful that it's
these sort of people
that will end up getting affected by it
and we
we want to try and ensure that we don't
forget
that what the work that these people
have done that are
in either in care homes or in
or or the way the tower staff have done
uh
when when all this has settled down
because
it's easy to forget that the lower end
of the the scale
uh pay scale and everything like that so
we would like some reassurances on that
but i think if if we could just
just clarify uh my exactly what the
amendment is because i did miss a little
bit of that
what we're voting for and i think
as long as we the sentiments there i
think we're all agreeing
the sentiment in that motion is right
but you know that nobody should be
suffering
with alzheimer's in any in any sort of
level
uh and and if we can help in that
process
by doing a proper scrutiny review and
adding them to
people i i i'd be happy with that
thank you councillor ridgeway
yes thank you for that um i take on
board everything
that's been said and i i wholeheartedly
agree with councillor
barker but i do uh i do feel that we
need to be looking at uh the mental
health of p of
everybody that um has had to go through
the covid19
so it's not just about the alzheimer's
and dementia
kobe 19 has affected people uh
tremendously and
has caused dementia and mental health
and it has caused lots of problems with
people that have worked in that
situation me for one
having worked in it and i can assure you
it's one of the most horrific
things that i have ever ever had to deal
with
and i would never wish anybody
sitting you know off all these
counsellors to go through what i have
had to go through and see what i have
gone through because my mental health
has been totally and utterly affected
so i think if we're going to to be doing
it it needs to go to every single
scrutiny
and i think we need to have probably
somebody that uh
people that have been affected to be
able to go along and talk about what's
happened because until you've actually
been there
seen it done it and got the t-shirt then
i don't think anybody can actually
um say what's gone off and what's not
gone off
thank you councillor thank her
thank you chair i think um i i accept
what council ridgeway
said i think mental health and
well-being during this covid period has
been a
severe um downside of what's happening
in this pandemic for many many people
i don't want it to be wrapped up with
the dementia situation i think they're
two separate things
and both equally important um having had
family members myself who
suffered from and to use that phrase
which you shouldn't
um dementia and alzheimer's i i felt
this um
motion didn't go far enough and the
reason i support council foster's
amendment is it just takes it back to
saying the thanks and so on at this
moment in time
but then the work can go back to
scrutiny
because um i think the survey is all
well and good but there's already
recognized data
about dementia and alzheimer's in
northeast derbyshire
i would prefer to see what we do next as
more action-focused
working with local charities and groups
supporting them and what they're doing
to
tackle alzheimer's and and dementia not
just for the people themselves but for
their families
because it's also hard for them and also
for the council to look at
targeted work with the clinical
commissioning group and public health
organizations
and look at a whole raft of other things
that we can be doing
that goes beyond just doing a survey a
survey is only one tiny part of it and i
think going back to
um the scrutiny committees we could
actually talk to professionals
people who've actually been in that
situation with family members and so on
and we can put together a role a more
robust
approach from this council to deal with
this so i support the amendment
thank you councillor foster now is there
out of reply on his amendment
yeah thank you chair um yeah just to
make clear
what the amendment is following from
what council barca requested
um that the motion as it stands
where it says council knows the first
three points
the last point that says that often
these early stage cases are not
receiving support from gps of adult
social care
that one is removed so the first three
points stand
that we note them but not the fourth one
where it says council resolves to thank
all of our staff and members for their
excellent work
that stays to proactively support the
chair in her work with alzheimer's
research
uk full stop and then perhaps one more
small thing
uh where it says the third note
that those individuals and families who
are suffering perhaps we can make that
uh for those who are living with i think
that's the term we use now so those who
are living with
so that's what i would like to change as
it stands what i'd like to make
very very clear not for one minute am i
recommending that
this council with this amendment
that we're sending this to scrutiny i'm
not recommending that we send it to
scrutiny
i'm recommending that individual
counselors that are part of these
scrutiny committees
can approach their scrutiny committees
and bring it forward there
whichever ones they choose to we've got
all groups of representatives i believe
on all of these scrutiny
committees so i'm not recommending in
this amendment that it goes to a
scrutiny committee
what i'm saying is as i originally
explained that if
the libyan councillors wish
to put this uh to the council or put
this to
uh to get the district council to uh to
do these
um district-wide surveys it should be
done
through that method i'm not recommending
that it goes there
when it goes there if if it does go then
they put it forward and a particular
commit scrutiny committee picks it up
at that point they can call who whoever
they want whichever witnesses
whichever professionals and indeed
whichever members here
have got experience with dealing with
dementia
and alzheimer's so i hope that's clear
but
i thank you for your support to council
barca
[Music]
thank you councillor dale
thank you just just to add my support to
council foster's amendment i think
uh it is correct that uh a suggestion
for a survey of this nature does go
forward
um to a scrutiny committee but raised by
an individual councillor
at that scrutiny i think some of the
debate we've had today highlights the
the issues we have in terms of
prioritization we've had
alzheimer's raised as an issue as well
as mental health and of course both
are very serious priorities and both
both are very
important issues but um i do think it's
right that these matters are brought
forward to a scrutiny committee
that is the appropriate place where they
should be put forward and
and and i would hope that uh the
councillor winley uh you know feels able
to to to do that
so i'm happy to support the the
amendment as proposed by
uh councillor foster move to the vote
please chair
uh council anne carp to speak
thank you chair obviously i haven't
actually spoken on council foster's
amendment yet
so there's a point of clarification
earlier um the key thing that i would
remind members now that council fosters
just raised the issue about scrutiny
is that scrutiny cannot set policy
it cannot set priorities it can make
recommendations
and council of foster council barca
both sit on scripting committees so
they're well aware of that fact
i think without doubt and i
what there has been a little bit of
pedantry here i think without doubt
every single one of us
is in support of at least the basic
principles there are
people who are stuck in
the early stages of not knowing where to
go
so i think it's important that we do i
actually
i'm going to vote against council
foster's amendment purely because i
think it actually
takes away um and to be truthful given
that it actually takes away any
proactivity
i'm not even sure it's a legitimate
amendment as truth is told
um and i'm sure the managing officer
will make a a
kind of a a guided decision on there but
it
i would say he's new today um so i i
would kind of like to hear the
monitoring officer's opinion on that
the the aim of the motion is to actually
get something on the way
and something started so that we can
come up with a service that actually
benefits the huge numbers of people
i mean betty i i remember julie very
well
and and it breaks your heart to know
that the experiences that families have
been in in those kind of situations
and um we need to try and do something
we are limited as a district council
in terms of what we can do um so i'm
just really
crying outside to say let's try and do
what we can do and take some proactive
action
um rather than rather than kind of get
tied up and just say
say no but thank you
yeah uh personal explanation chair i'll
take that insult on the chin from david
hancock
uh i don't mind let's move to the vote
thank you can we now move to the vote on
the amendment
jeff i did want to speak i'm sorry
please do before you move to the vote
right go ahead tracy thank you
um i was just going to say you know i do
feel that we need to support
the amendment i do believe that scrutiny
is probably the best place for this to
be
looked at and i would sort of try and
hope as a former
scrutiny chair myself to say to
councillor hancock and and the other lib
dem counselors to reassure them is that
to hold a a review and and perhaps
suggest this as a topic where the
spotlight can be truly put onto it
and and and really be in-depthly looked
at is much better than trying to come up
with a one-shot
survey which probably like counselor
thakur has already said would only give
you very limited
information and is what you would you
know get from using a survey
a scrutiny review a topic chosen
specifically to highlight and put the
spotlight on this area
in my opinion would be more beneficial
and hopefully reach what you would want
it to
you know to do and so for that i think
it would be you know better to go with
the amendment
so that was just the point i wanted to
make sure thank you
this
councillor windley would you like to
write reply you must a minute
okay um yeah just to say that
um the discussion um about
the um gp support it's
it wasn't ever a criticism
i've walked down this road three times
with people who are supported with
dementia
alzheimer's right from the beginning and
right until the
end i've sat new year's eve in 2019
with someone who had been through this
journey and i've been with them
and they passed away i know what it's
like
the early stages it's very difficult for
gps and
social care to come in and
support much needed help
it's very difficult the point system
that they've got to work with even to to
get the budget in place for extra help
coming in
and the isolation that the families can
lead
so it was never ever a um
criticism the best way we can
can get help for people that's walking
down this path together
and i'm happy to go along with as long
as they get help that's all i want
thank you
can we now move to the vote on the
amendment
thank you chair is everybody content to
move
to a vote on the amendment or does
anybody want it reading out again
okay that is everybody is content in
which case can you switch your cameras
on please and put your hands up if
you're voting for the amendment
i have that sarah thank you
can i have everybody who is voting
against the amendment
please switch on your camera and put
your hand up
thank you another anybody is there
anybody who is abstaining please you
switch your camera on and put your hand
up
no abstention thank you chairman the
amendment is carried and becomes a
substantive motion
um do you wish to take the vote on the
substantive motion
yes please um i think that's a [ __ ] man
once exercise is right to reply
so council shipment thank you chair um i
must say i'm disappointed that that
amendment as it was worded has passed i
did agree with some of it but i think
the
the um maybe uh warranted and wanted
um subsequent to uh
subsequently to that passing i think
what he's done now is taking
all the me off the bones of the motion
because um
i'm not sure if councillor i mean
council foster is a scrutiny chair i
believe and he
it baffles me that it's sat there saying
that
suddenly the scrutiny committees
should should be the ones setting
policy for the council to scrutinize
actually it's the other way around the
council sets a policy and the scrutiny
committees
scrutinize whatever the council have
agreed and therefore
it should be cancelled saying we are
going to proceed with a
certain path and then the scrutiny
whichever one we choose to put in the
motion granted it could have been worded
better but the ones we put into the
motion
would then deal with it i find it i
guess belief that
you would have eight different scrutiny
committees looking at the same issue
getting in the same people giving
evidence i mean is that
what we call an efficient because that's
not efficient to me what we should have
done is name the scrutiny committee
which we felt was best to deal with this
and then they go ahead and deal with it
and getting
people getting evidence and whatnot to
create
a survey which we all think is decent
it's going to have cross-party support
the survey would have
and then that could go out to the people
in north east starbucks so i i
i do think council foster needs to kind
of understand the council structure a
bit better instead of
thinking it's the other way around to
what it actually is in practice
um i will support the motion however
even though it's different to what i
wish i do think that there needs to be
one particular
individual perhaps it's council winsley
on one of her committees that she's on
that takes this forward rather than
having eight different
scrutiny committees looking at the same
issue because i just don't think that's
efficient
and especially when we're talking about
council resources being stretched
to to suggest it's a free-for-all and
whoever decides to take this issue and
run with it
is then putting it on their committee is
such a back-to-front way of doing it and
i
and i like to say i i think that we need
to just
even if we have the discussion outside
the council meeting some one person
needs to take it forward to a committee
and just
let's do it on one committee rather than
eight thank you chair
thank you the amendment is now the
substantive motion can we now
vote upon that please
thank you chair all those in favor of
the motion as amended please can you
show by putting your cameras on and
lifting your hands
that's sarah thank you can those who are
against the motion as amended please put
your cameras on and lift your hands
thank you is there anybody who wishes to
abstain
the motion as amended is carried
thank you
now we're on titan 14 in the chairs
urgent business
and i can say i have no urgent business
today so i declare the meeting closed
thank you for your attendance
today thank you did we thank martin
thacker by the way
not enough time
you